a strong but peaceful show of strength
by catholics in sri lanka
these people want justice for the 270
killed in six bomb attacks
on easter sunday in 2019.
seven of them were from teresa pierce's
family
her son her daughter and five
grandchildren
they went happily expecting to come back
but only their bodies returned
i'm asking that these issues are not
avoided by the authorities who are
enabling these tragedies to be repeated
eight suicide bombers detonated bombs in
churches and hotels
in a series of attacks they were blamed
on a local extremist group
affiliated to isil but many suspect
others were involved after two years of
waiting
the church is now campaigning for
answers
this is not a struggle between religions
race or politics
but it's a struggle of fear over unfair
light over darkness
justice over injustice the report of a
presidential inquiry into the bombings
was handed over in february
it says since 2015 the government did
not prioritize national security instead
prioritizing unity and reconciliation
witnesses said the government did not
take action against religious extremism
not only president sirisena and premier
riku masingay
but the entire government must take
responsibility we are more interested in
finding out who did it
who funded it and why did they do it the
church says black sunday
marks the first step of a journey to
secure justice
the bloodstains are long gone the qatar
peter church you see behind me
has been repainted but church leaders
say there will be no
closure until justice is served and the
identities of those behind
the easter bombings are revealed
mila fernandez al-jazeera katupitia